[Music]
we're back now with a look at how the
coronavirus has devastated small
businesses and their
employees you've probably heard times
are tough but you may not realize just
how tough they are
for small businesses researchers at
harvard university in fact harvard
business school
estimate that one out of every seven
small businesses
as a result of the virus have closed
permanently
think about that earlier this year we
spoke to
employees who were laid off from a small
business in elmsford new york
and the owner who was trying to hold
things together there any way he could
recently we went back to them to see if
anything has changed
it was pretty gut wrenching to be honest
when we met joe gilderson back in march
he just laid off
most of his 20 workers at corporate av
for a company that handles lighting and
sound at large events
he predicted a struggle to make it
through the shutdown if we don't have
work by the fall then
i don't know if we're around at that
point now with the fall just five weeks
away
gilderson says he's still hanging on all
right it's no longer a race
this is going to be a marathon he says
corporate av survived in part because of
funding from the federal government's
paycheck protection program
we kicked the can down the road so to
speak the federal money
bailed you out kept you afloat it's
absolutely
one of the things to keep us afloat the
other was trying to come up with another
way to do things
the company shifted to hosting online
events which bring in less money
and require fewer people that leaves
former employee mo
johnson in much of the same place we
found him months ago
do whatever you can to save the company
save the ship when we get back on the
ship we can go again
what have you been up to since we last
talked to you sitting on the couch
cooking a lot and doing
odd kind of jobs those jobs include
webcasting a high school graduation
as a freelancer for corporate av not an
employee
what's it been like for you
psychologically to go four months
without
being able to say i have a job this is
my job it's weird
my wife and i actually had a spat today
she said
um you know you should go to the dentist
and i'm like we don't have insurance
and it's that's weird i don't care you
should still go it's only 150
and i'm like before it was not a
discussion
now it's like wow the things we have to
put off
more than 5 million laid off workers
lost their health insurance during the
pandemic
and nearly 4 out of every 10 americans
say they face a major threat to their
personal finances
gabenell is among them yeah i don't see
the alive events industry coming back
anytime soon
as he waits for things to pick up again
today's mixtape is called
dreaming and believing he's now hosting
a heavy metal podcast
every morning from his kitchen i guess
it keeps my sanity you know
five months ago when he lost his job at
corporate av
anell and his wife claudia told us they
didn't quite know
how they would move forward so april 1st
are you going to make a mortgage payment
or not
good question we haven't even talked
about that you're just constantly
worried about
like can i make this payment can i put
my kid
you know can i get a doctor even before
even before
since then claudia lost her mother to
covid19
but even as the family deals with that
loss they've been able to control the
financial pain
so far claudia wasn't home when we
stopped by because
she was able to return to her work as a
property manager
after quarantining at home and gabe told
us the federal government's weekly 600
dollar unemployment benefit helped pay
the bills
that benefit of course has since expired
there's nerves there's stress there's
there's a constant anxiety
and i know my wife's feeling the anxiety
too because we know at the end of this
month
we really don't know what we're gonna do
we're literally back to where the last
time you guys were here
wow we don't know what we're gonna do at
the end of this month
there's been laughter he tells us along
with the tears
and he says he is hopeful that things
will turn around
eventually if the work comes back we
come back
and look if i can't go back there
because there's no work
i can't go anywhere to look for work and
what i do
so what kind of timetable do you have in
your mind
for when you might be able to add
employees
with benefits like you had before i
don't really know
i mean i was hoping in fall that was it
was always the plan
so i think you know we're still trying
to keep that ship afloat
yeah we got a long way to go
so guilderson is now predicting that
maybe next spring things will pick up
and i'll be able to rehire his employees
now
i want to put a spotlight on on
something one of his employees said
uh that was mo right in the middle of
the story he talked about putting off
uh dental work because when he lost his
job he lost his health insurance
that is the kind of bleak choice that
millions of people in this country are
facing right now maybe it's not the
doctor it's the rent maybe it's not the
doctor it's the credit card
maybe it's it's lunch they got to skip
it because they got to make it to dinner
and so i think there's really what i
could describe as toxic
uncertainty right now as they wait for
benefit checks yeah the domino effect of
this is huge
and and the uncertainty is it it affects
everybody i was talking to a band
manager
who said he's now planning for no
concerts at all next year
because he has to expect the worst and
hope for the best
i'm so glad you're telling these stories
tony i was two were struck by mo's words
this pandemic is real this coronavirus
is real we're sick of it but it is not
done with us yet
another reminder thank you tony decopol